Let's go next to I hope I'm pronouncing this
correctly. Is it Keyon in Queens or is it KION?
Hi, it's Cayenne Kion, all right, all
right, so the first one was wrong,
but I got it right on the second try, right.
Good job. What's going on? I love your show. And
I have two questions. Sure. The first one is about
my prediction that Kamala Harris will be running
in twenty twenty four and probably nominating me
as a VP if she decides that sexual orientation is
not a risk. OK. Anyway, I think that Kamala smart
enough to know that her and Biden cannot piss off
the progressives during their term and otherwise.
The turnout in twenty twenty four would be,
you know, if it's even just five percent
lower, it could be detrimental to her chances.
So my instinct tells me that she would push
Biden to do a few more things that would
make progressives happy so that she can tell her
accomplishments during her presidential run next
time. So, for example, student loan forgiveness
would be one thing that I would think that she
would be pushing, because I would see I don't
see really any negative to Biden increasing his
his his idea about I guess it's ten thousand.
He wants to forgive now, but I don't see
that any negative to him increasing that. And I
just think that all the people that would feel
the relief from that student loan forgiveness
would remember in twenty, twenty four and they
would be more excited and have a reason
to actually come out to vote for her. So.
So a few thoughts on that, a few thoughts on
that, a couple of different things. No. One,
remember, Joe Biden can't get a lot of the things
done. I don't actually think Joe Biden can do
even the student loan thing if he doesn't
get control of the Senate. I just don't know.
I don't I don't believe you can do that via
executive order. And I don't see how he gets
student loan forgiveness done without Democrats
controlling the Senate. So it's very important to
understand that a lot of what you're talking about
is is very nuanced and important and reasonable.
But it's not simply up to, oh, does Comilla make
sure Joe Biden throws some bones to progressives
to help him or her in twenty twenty four? It's
not just up to Comilla convincing Joe Biden
there's realities here where without the Senate, I
don't see how any of this stuff gets done. That's
that's sort of like number one. Number two, I
do agree. And, you know, there was this earlier
caller about how does how do progressives keep
Biden accountable if if Democrats take the Senate,
the way they keep Biden accountable is they can't
Biden can't afford to lose a single Democratic
vote in the Senate. And that includes Joe Manchin
as much as that includes Bernie Sanders. So I
think that's the answer to that piece. But a lot
of what you're saying is spot on, except it's not
up to Comilla to convince Joe because it's
legislatively difficult without the Senate.
OK.
Thanks and I have a second
question related to Nina Turner, and she
recently announced that she's running for
Ohio's 11th District. OK, so I feel like really
excited about this opportunity, having at least
one more non corrupt person and in Congress.
And I feel the same way that I felt when,
like your girlfriend, it ran for a seat in
California. So when Genk ran and announced
his candidacy, I was like so hopeful and I was
almost certain that he would pull out a win,
given his national profile and
support from across the nation.
And so, as you may know and
your viewers might know, that
James got trounced by the establishment candidate
in California and that really surprised me.
So do you see any similarities with do you
see any similarities with Nina's candidacy
where it looks like she would be a shoo
in with such a national profile and lots
of grass roots funding available to her yet?
I really don't know, to be perfectly frank. I
don't know enough about that district and I don't
know enough about the level to which Nina is known
nationally. Like I know about her and I know she
appears on national media with relative frequency.
I just don't have all the information. It might
be a similar situation to Genk or she might end up
wiping the floor in the 11th. I just don't know
enough to be able to say about that district.
OK, well, I'll just remain hopeful
about both issues with Carmela
trying to push by that and
hopefully easing our way.
And thank you for your time and I enjoy your show.
Thank you. I appreciate the call. And it seems
to quote myself on previous calls. It seems
like there's a lot going on there. So we're
going to let you I'm going to let you
go. But I really do appreciate the call.